vous avez été beaucoup critiquée qu'est
ce que je pourrais faire comme vidéo
originale mais qui reste fidèle à mon
univers
pageau afghane c'est fou ça que la prod
c'est notre vie à tous evga quand y'a
pas témoin aux toilettes je me lave
quand même les mains lors d'une soirée
net du stade on voit le film jusqu'à la
fin j'ai vraiment le tout les cas bdom
la bibliothèque tout ça plus de dix ans
maintenant les médias ne respecte
mi-temps d'allemands c'est vraiment
super utile dans la vie quand j'ai va en
boîte en coupe tu t'amuses monsieur mans
les charges et tender c'est juste pour
tester la vie au la blague d'enlever la
casquette des gens c'est hyper marrant
[Musique]
de couleurs après tout le monde à
montjaux digue me sert à faire du
jogging
j'irai mais jamais un caleçon deux jours
de suite que donnerait pas le code de
mon portable mais j'ai rien à cacher ma
meilleure idée sont celles que j'ai
souvent quand je dis que c'est la
dernière fois je vois c'est bien la
dernière fois pendant tdf te propose un
iphone c'est vraiment moi en offrir et
plus tard ton cadeau d'anniv quand elle
se met la balle perdue tu tiens taxi par
contre c'est vrai
[Musique]
pour tepco
marie que ce soutien soit même au réveil
le débat chocolatines pains au chocolat
et passionnant or les bébés papam est
une petite graine dans maman origone
souvent de choses que tu fais dote des
galbas autour du burger et celui
services sont ressemblants combien face
est vraiment passé comme tu l'imaginés
occultée en coupe takamura était turbo
put mais au fond de la classe et parce
que tu vois mieux de loin pas capables
de citer une chanson du groupe dont tu
portes le tee shirt c'est vrai groupe ce
ton t-shirt à te connais pas le rameau
nes c'est à ces facteurs
ils ont fait quoi ils ont fait à ce mot
rythme quand j'étais petit
j'étais un enfant
je n'avais pas beaucoup d'amis je me
suis réfugié dans le monde
nivet j'étais un mec normal en fait j
[Musique]
vous
comment tout va
allez
chez vous
ce sens
toronto
cherbourg solaire taux d'achat tant
convoité traduction merci pour le
visionnage montrez-moi votre puissance
en lâchant un groupe housse en l'air à
cette vidéo tarn trappe
pourquoi
[Musique]